welcome back here with the incredibly
charming host of the new game show cash
at your door our dear friend jason biggs
i was reading a bunch of stuff that we
could discuss but i wanted actually one
bit uh amongst many conversations a bit
of parenting advice oh um because
like i have become this mother
that is ironically
very
chaste very pillars of appropriateness
and
i tell my daughters all the time i'm
liking the truth is
you're gonna find out that i wasn't
always like that
and you're gonna be uber confused
but what i need you to remember when you
see pictures of me or my wild stuff
a lot of times we think of it in the
terms of like art and expression and
you know i loved fashion and photography
and we made movies where
we did you know either a scene or two or
or three sure um
i'm picking up what you're throwing down
drew and
i'm like i'm how do you handle that yeah
how old is your oldest nine yeah i'm uh
my oldest is almost eight and it's the
same conversations that jenny and i have
uh i'm glad that i have boys
right like i'm for whatever reason maybe
it's just my own comfort but i feel like
it'll be easier to address with them
right um
and yeah i i guess it's tricky it's like
what is the age because you don't want
them to discover it before you talk to
them about it necessarily my son
said laszlo has no idea um but but but
sid
has been aware enough of people coming
up to me and saying american pie and pie
and he's he's used enough
context clues
people have specifically mentioned the
oh my god that thing you did and he's
you know like what did you do exactly
and he's starting to ask the questions
yeah and i just tell them
[Applause]
so that's how we so that's how we deal
with it what about you
i literally tell my girls i'm like
here's the deal i go with humor you are
literally going to see so many mixed
messages you are going to be like but
mom
look at what you did yeah cause that's
the other thing you don't know you're
going to be a parent one day when you're
figuring it all out none of us are like
well you know one day this is going to
be catalog i can tell you the very last
thing i was thinking about when i had a
pie in my uh
region
was uh having a kid one day
that was in fact if anything i was like
i'm never going to be able to have kids
maybe that's what i was thinking
i never thought about it either i was
just living my life and trying to figure
out what it was and they will live
theirs and they will understand and if
it's not now it'll be later that they
will understand i mean i i'd say one of
the craziest things about parenting for
me and i wonder this if you feel the
same way has been
all of the things that i was sort of
resentful towards my parents about
oh that you know why would you just say
that or do that or no or fight with them
about it's like i'm now understanding
you know they always said like just wait
till you're a parent i'd be like don't
say that to me i'm not a parent and then
and now i'm a parent i'm like oh yeah
yeah i
okay i get it i get it and it's like you
know what that'll happen with them yeah
you know it's all gonna
take its its course you know it'll
happen but
this is my favorite chapter of life as
parenting it's the hardest and it's the
most challenging and it's the most
exhausting yeah but it is the most
fulfilling
eye-opening incredible
what rewarding it's rewarding yeah this
is my interview if you could please
[Applause]
before you go i think we have time for
one more round of cash what you're
[Applause]
last seeing out here is lachey ortiz
lachey
hi lachey
come on down how you doing lachey i'm
doing great thank you for all that you
do because i know
that you're a volunteer
um and you donate a lot of your time at
food banks
i feel like we should
i feel like we should up the stakes for
lachey
i think we should all right let's see
what's gonna happen if you answer this
question right okay you will win
a thousand dollars a thousand dollars
wait wait really a thousand dollars
[Applause]
all right are you ready yes no presh
here we go
halloween is the spookiest time of year
with many things to be frightful of
acrophobia is the fear of what is it
spiders acronyms heights or confined
places acrophobia
uh i think it's heights
no the correct answer
is
[Applause]
[Music]
you